right there have some brand new
information what do you know brett
i guess uh we can confirm from two
intelligence sources that al qaeda
leader ayman al-zawahiri has been killed
by a cia drone strike in afghanistan
over the weekend and that is what
president biden will announce from the
white house tonight at 7 30 eastern time
you'll remember zawahiri was a deputy
under osama bin laden on 9 11. he is one
of the most wanted terrorists has been
for a long time here's the fbi sheet on
him he took over the leadership after
the death of bin laden and was
considered to be
at one point possibly dead but just a
report in the past a couple of months
said that he could be operating in
afghanistan communicating with
terrorists
this is again two intelligence sources
saying that this is a big
counter-terrorism win for the u.s ayman
al-zawahiri killed in this drone strike
this comes as al qaeda we don't talk
about terrorism a lot we talked about
isis for a long time but al qaeda was
making a resurgence and is making a
resurgence in the middle east considered
to be very uh dangerous still
and this is a major major get uh the
next in command is a guy named seif
al-adl long-time al-qaeda leader and
veteran second-in-command tazawihiri
assumed that he would take control of
the organization
but we'll hear more details as we get
them from cia drone strike over the
weekend
so brett was this spontaneous do you
know or was this a staged operation uh
like with osama bin laden
this was a drone strike with active
intel they had an
intelligence we're being told that
zawahiri is was at a certain residence
outside kabul it's hard to believe after
all these years that just outside a
major city in afghanistan where the u.s
had been operating for a long time
is this al qaeda leader they acted on
that intelligence we're told that it was
a drone strike we don't know the
confirmation and what led to their
confidence that it is our hiri
but
again
you're going to hear a moment tonight
uh that will be president biden's bin
laden moment because he will give a
speech we're told uh that deals with the
fight against terrorism that has been
ongoing uh even though we haven't talked
about it a lot ayman al-zawihiri you see
on the screen there had been a a leader
a spiritual leader and also someone who
is fomanting terrorism in different
groups around the world this is a huge
huge win for the u.s
and
we expect to hear that and where the
fight goes from here as far as taking
out other terrorists katie hey brett uh
good to see you and thanks for bringing
the news to us so the bite
administration argued after the
withdrawal from afghanistan which the
one year anniversary is coming up at the
end of the month which we know did not
go well that they would have the
capability with the over horizon drone
strikes and cia intelligence to continue
to go after terrorism in afghanistan so
can you talk about what that means with
that backdrop and given the strike that
we're going to hear more about from the
president tonight that's a great point
uh katie this will be this will back up
uh some of the concerns that critics of
the obama administration had that they
would not have
these eyes to be able to follow up on
leads on the ground
if everything we're hearing is accurate
and we believe it to be true
they had some active intelligence from
people on the ground they were working
with and that led to this residence and
it led to the cia drone strike so that
over the horizon strike capability uh
was there despite the concern still
about uh where afghanistan is with the
taliban and without uh kind of guidance
of u.s forces at least
in over the horizon uh capability jesse
well obviously a great win for the
united states and a clear victory over
terrorism politically for the president
we've just talked about in the a block
how the administration and some of the
media had been framing this as the
resurgence of the biden presidency at a
few things about to be passed
in congress and now this big
strike announcement tonight do you think
the president's going to look to
capitalize on this momentum and head
into august after being down for
quite some time on the mat 100 jesse i
mean listen you can't take away that
this has been a couple of good weeks for
the president who has been we haven't
seen too much of he's been behind the
scenes with covid uh but he
is at least on the precipice of a couple
of legislative wins we don't know if
it'll all line up but it seems like it
is and uh obviously got the chips bill
now with this announcement uh again
it will be a positive you can't look it
at it any other way and it will not take
away from the horrible nature in which
we got out of afghanistan but it will
enable them to make the case that
they're still fighting terrorists around
the globe greg
i know the answer will probably be i
don't know but i'm going to ask you
anyway brett that you know they do say
there are no casualties this is a this
is a big strike
uh but it's always hard to believe to
hear that when they say it's a residence
and uh when they're weighing you know
the collateral damage how do we know
that there's no
casualties we know there's one casualty
yes um but we we don't know about the
other details and again it's
um we're just getting pieces of this uh
to get that confirmation about who it
was uh was what we're trying to do but
you're right i mean any of these strikes
drone strikes
can be messy they're precision to the
target but you don't know what's in or
around the target so hopefully we'll get
some more information tonight
jessica
hi brad thanks for joining us i was
curious if you thought that this was
going to kind of usher in a new era or
at least certainly multiple news cycles
of talking about islamic terrorism again
it feels like we talked about it a bit
obviously with the withdrawal from
afghanistan but before that it had been
years and years before it was really
a focus with us so do you think that
this changes that landscape i do i i
think that uh it just gets back into
people's minds about where we were in
hunting these people down after 9 11.
think about how many you know i was at
the pentagon at that time over those
years as the hunt for bin laden was
continuing and there was still a hunt
for zawahiri back then and all the
questions about where he could be and
and the mountains between afghanistan
and pakistan
and here you know is a successful strike
right outside kabul i think it will
bring to the forefront the thing it's
just not in the front of people's minds
is because we haven't fortunately had a
big terrorist attack uh here in in a
long time there have been inspired
attacks but al qaeda is still out there
and i think that'll be something the
president talks about is the threats
that still face the u.s all right brett
thanks so much for joining us we will be
watching special report in about 25
minutes you bet hi everyone i'm brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now